Welcome back guys, I'm Nate, and thank you for joining me. today
We're going to be doing a few different experiments using proto puddy.
In the past we have showed you how to make your own proto puddy and several cool
Experiments that you can do with it. today
We're gonna try out some experiments that a few people have asked about
We've got four different things that we're gonna try out with our proto puddy today. We're going to freeze some in liquid nitrogen
We're going to burn some in our furnace
We're going to try and make a mold using a proto putty and then we're going to see if we can cast liquid metal
in that mold. The purpose of our video today is to run our proto puddy through a gauntlet of tests to see how it holds
Up under different conditions, we have a whole previous video on how to make proto putty, but let's go over the process really quick
We've got here our three ingredients that we need for making proto putty silicone one caulking food coloring and cornstarch to get started
Let's mix up a few small batches of proto putty that we can use to test freezing and burning.
Remember this stuff smells really strong so you're gonna want to make sure you have a well-ventilated area to mix it up
Remember when you're working with your proto potty as soon as it starts to stick to your hands add more cornstarch
All right, I've got my first batch of proto pudding mixed up. I'm gonna split it in two and try two different things
I'm gonna make a ball with one half and the other 1/2
I'm gonna spread out into a flat little plank that we can easily dip down into our liquid, nitrogen
Now mixing up a second small batch of proto putty, and I'm going to form it into two flat sticks to test in our furnace
Alright now. Let's mix up a little bit of blue proto putty and try to mold this 3d printed octopus
Doesn't even look blue. It looks black. It'll start looking blue as soon as I mix it
For this octopus
We're just doing a very basic press mold pushing our proto putty down all over the 3d print to give it a nice even coating
All right now we've got a couple of pieces of cured proto putty
And we're gonna see what happens when we dip them in liquid, nitrogen
You can see that the stuff is very flexible you can bend it you can squish it
You can twist it you can stretch it, and now we're gonna see if any of that changes once it freezes
So I'm gonna try two things the first is that I'm gonna
Let it sit in the liquid, nitrogen
Until it's good and cold then I'm gonna take it out and let it thaw and we'll see if anything has changed
After that I'm gonna take this piece of proto putty put it back in the liquid, nitrogen
Until its frozen solid and then I'm going to see if I can snap it in half
I also have a little ball of proto putty
Which is fairly bouncy, and I'm gonna see if it's still bouncy after it's been frozen in liquid, nitrogen
See it's boiling as it heats up from the proto putty but soon it will start all cooling off
Wow even the part of the proto Pete
Okay, that was unexpected it just shattered
problem the cold and fell entirely into the cup
Part of it was in the liquid nitrogen part of it wasn't while I was just trying to gently stir it around
It flopped and broke apart, and then the piece that wasn't in the liquid nitrogen fell down into the liquid nitrogen's
All right, I'm going to pour the liquid nitrogen off into this other Cup so I can take those pieces of proto putty out oh
That's weird it sounds like pieces of tile or ceramic in there you hear that
Alright, let's pour them out oh
my gosh
our protocol has
Just broken into pieces here. All right. Well. I'm doing this out of order, but because I have an extra piece
I'm gonna try snapping this. Yep, just like no resistance at all. That's very weak
It feels about like breaking a piece of chalk all right
Let's let these pieces warm back up and see what happens to them
I'm curious if they'll go back to being flexible and squishy like they were before
Right now obviously. They're not flexible at all and they just snap even if you don't do anything
They just break spontaneously from the cold which I did not see coming
While we're waiting for those pieces to warm back up let's drop our ball into the liquid nitrogen and see what happens to it
At this point I suspect it's gonna break into pieces
Bubbles are getting smaller so the proto putty is cooling down
Hmm, I wonder if the ball is gonna crack or not
That's a cool effect of liquid nitrogen fumes flow just barely over the lip of the cup
And then they run down the sides kind of sticking to it
You can see that the vapors go in with the incline of the cup all right
I think that's probably as cold as it's gonna get I heard one little crack sound but not much else so let's just pour off
The nitrogen and take the ball out and let's see what happens to it
Oh
And now it popped in my hand
Coming out of the nitrogen I wonder if it's just the the heat from my hand or the heat from the air or just that
It was ready to pop and it's just not it's moving now. Well. I was gonna see if it'll bounce now
I think I'm gonna see if it'll just shatter into a bunch of pieces. Let's try that
Well, actually that still bounced. It just didn't bounce like a bouncy ball
Nothing it's not really shattering. It's just breaking along the lines
Where it had already cracked in the liquid nitrogen so at this point?
Let's let it warm back up and see what happens to it. They almost look like little gummy candies
They will be gummy, but they aren't candy our first piece of proto putty has warmed back up now
Let's see what the texture is like and if it still has the same flexibility that it had before
Let tears really easily
Like it doesn't seem nearly as tough as it was
weird
so it tears and then there's this like white film on the very outside that kind of holds together the
Inside just breaks through really easily, but something on the outside
Really tough. All right. Let's try one of these bigger piece and see what happens if you break them oh
Those cracks
All through it I wonder if that's just something else that cracked from the pölten. I couldn't see it, but
Yeah that stuff Wow
before I could twist this and
Pull it and squish it and now it just is like ripping to pieces immediately
Weird whoa? This one's even more broken pieces look at it. Okay. That's not even holding itself together
Okay, these pieces are mostly warmed back up
Let's see if they've got any bounce they aren't round so they certainly aren't going to bounce nice and up-and-down
But let's see if it will at least have some ricochet to it
That seems kind of bouncy
Kind of like bouncing an eraser, maybe it's not like a bouncy ball, but it definitely has some spring to it
Our octopus mold is ready. Let's peel it off and see how it's turned out there we go
This is looking good
All right look at that that did pretty well
You can even see the details of the print lines from the 3d print as a mold making material
I think this actually works pretty
Well it picks up a lot of good detail as long as you make sure to press the proto putty
Carefully into all of the nooks and crannies
I think if you have any sort of resin or casting plastic that should work really well in this silicone putty
I do have to warn you should not ever use proto putty as a mold for food
There are a lot of chemicals coming off of proto putty that can make your food toxic in just a minute
We'll fire up the furnace and see if we can cast aluminum in the proto putty mold
We've also got two pieces of proto putty. We're gonna throw right into the furnace and we'll see you it happens
Maybe they'll burn maybe they'll melt
Okay our furnace is heating up and starting to melt some aluminum and while it's getting hot enough
We're going to try in this piece of proto putty to see what happens to it
Before going in it's nice and flexible just like the other proto puddi was we'll see what happens when it's done
You might just burn up. I don't know Oh
Immediately you see the edges start earning it starts getting all bubbly
That looks like a badly burned marshmallow
Yeah, that is on fire that's a cool fire vortex tornado thing going on there
Smells weird, but it almost has the tiniest hint of like a fruity smell like if you burn a pie
I think that's the acetic acid from the silicone
Now interestingly even though this stuff has been burned pretty badly. It's still quite flexible, so
Burning it it retains a lot more of its properties than freezing it apparently
It's a little bit sticky so maybe it did start melting a little bit as well as burning
I'm gonna see if I can just tear it apart by pulling oh
Yeah, that still tears pretty easily, so I'd say it did weaken it well there
You go still red on the inside of the thicker areas
All right my aluminum is nice, and hot I'm gonna pull out the crucible and then pour the liquid aluminum into our proto potting mold
And it's on fire
And it's spilling over the edge, and it's still on fire
The proto putty mold is burning
Still pretty liquid, so I don't really want to get anywhere near it in case it decides to start popping and exploding oh
It just I blew it out and the heat just lit it right back on fire
We poured the liquid aluminum into our pro to putty mold and the pro to putty mold quickly lit on fire
So I think that means that it's not gonna be a great mold material for liquid metal
We actually got a little bit of the shape of the octopus's head right there. It's not very clean
It didn't get any of the tentacles and it did light our mold on fire, but a little bit of octopus head did get cast
There you have it guys for different experiments with proto putty
We've tried freezing it in liquid, nitrogen
Burning in the furnace making a mold out of it and casting liquid metal into it we had some mixed results
freezing the proto putty in liquid, nitrogen
I thought it was going to freeze then it would thaw and it would return to its normal state
But in freezing it cracked and started breaking into pieces all on its own
And when I had thought it was very fragile and didn't hold itself together very well
Burning the proto putty did go about as I expected it
Just started charring and bubbling and burning it smelled bad lit on fire and in the end
It's not really good for anything it might still be a little bit flexible
But it's also gummy and burned and black and it smells weirder than normal
And I wouldn't recommend that you burn this for any reason. There's no advantage to it making a mold out of proto putty
I thought worked very well
We got a lot of detail pulled from our 3d printed octopus
And we had a mold that would have worked really well for most kinds of resins however
Pouring molten aluminum into that mold did not work very well the proto putty
Just lit on fire
Immediately and the metal casting didn't come out well at all so I can't recommend using proto potti as a mold for casting metal
Lots of things that we've learned about proto putty today if you've made something cool about proto putty
Tell me about it down in the comments
I want to know what things you've come up with thanks for joining us for this video today
And we'll see you in the next one talk to you then
Kind of looks like a giant stick of cinnamon gum
It's everywhere
Hey guys, I hope you're having a great day you are awesome
You are appreciated, and I know everyone over here my team is really grateful for you
Thanks so much for choosing to watch and support our videos. We'll see you in the next one